you know one that I just really love and
I don't think people talk about enough
it's Hemingway's first novel The Sun
Also Rises it's a gorgeous book you know
I mean my god i think it's it's just so
beautifully written and so honest and so
emotionally naked and in some ways it's
one of his best books and it's one of
his very first you know a lot of its
interesting a lot of young writers I've
noticed have a hard time with conflict
they summoned they bring in a lot of
guns in action in and you know
over-the-top conflict which is
understandable that's out in the world
but I try to tell them that trouble is
right there you know the quarter-inch
beneath the surface of everybody and so
here you know what I love about that
novel is the main character is young his
penis has been blown off but he still
has his testicles and all of his
feelings all of his sexual drive and
he's in love of the most beautiful woman
in Paris and she's screwing all of his
friends what more do you have to work
with and his isn't it a I'm gonna go
reread it and it has one of the best
last lines in literature I think
remember the last line she says Oh Jake
we could have had such a fine time and
his line is yes isn't it pretty to think
so
oh I think so I think you need a lot of
trouble I I think some of my earlier
writing is got a little too much trouble
in it although I was writing from the
point of view of people who committed
violent crimes and whatnot I think that
if if you're trying to write
character-driven fiction which I try to
do you know if you have a
three-dimensional human being and you
put him or her in a real landscape and
you let him or her engage with the
people in their lives trouble is going
to be there and yeah but yeah there's
you don't have a story without it I know
in writing classes we use the word
conflict but I think that's over dumb
because I think kids take it too
literally and think they need something
really major no trouble you know here's
trouble you're on a date and you think
your breath is bad that's all you need
you know you're in a job interview and
you have to go to the bathroom that's
the only your full bladder is enough
trouble and that seemed that they can
screw up the whole interview
no well but listen man there is nothing
nothing better in my opinion and having
kids and you know I'm not a guy who
thought about having kids when I didn't
have kids but not I've had them I just
feel as if my my life began after I
became a father really in a lot of ways
in it in a bigger spiritual way but yeah
there's less time but my my answer is
you don't care so what guess what
they're going to be you know you're
going to be driving them to games and
dance concerts in school and back and
for a short little window and then
you're going to wonder where they went
and I'm convinced you know if I live to
be an old man you never know what you
have I'm going to look back at these
years with my kids is the best years of
my life no matter what happens so yeah
sometimes it means less time the desk
but so what what they give you back is a
thousand times greater than what you
lose in my opinion and also i'll say
this i think the act of being of a
mother or father has only got to deepen
your writing about people because you
really hit this this uh well you love
harder and you hear lost more
you